was
underestimating you, but you can't make
money at a party so quickly.You must have heard the
rumors.And I was saved by the black D
guy stabbing me in the neck.Black
is fine.  That's
right, I'll
tell you that there are many people who deceived you, and the number of
people who hold a grudge against him has increased.  Little girls like aristocrats The public seems to be ignorant about the
Shinkansen Recently, they seem to have
taken care of even the
kids.  I
see.
[Laughter]
So, Nick, the
moment they were tricked and I burst into tears, I'd be sorry if you let me
bite you.  I do
n't have a hobby of tormenting cats
[music]
Don't do it,
you don't do it that much I want
money too It's great if you can get
money easily  Even if you
make a lot of money,
how good are the drinks you drink with that kind of money?
[Music] Have
you become so drunk already?